So what are the challenges that we're
going to face when we have this
task of managing cyber security for the
organization that we're talking about?
We said we have to know what
are the assets that are of value and
are they under risk?
Also, sort of understand the threats.
And, how serious are those threats?
So when we talk about risk, actually
we're going to look at this a little bit
more, but risk is really
the likelihood of an attack, okay?
So probability of an attack.
It's not the worst case but
the worst can happen.
It's sort of trying to compute
the likely case in some sense.
So continuing with the challenges,
even if I sort of identify my assets and
threat source, and
perhaps the likelihood of attacks,
then I have to worry about,
well what can I do about it?
What sort of solutions are out there or
controls that exist?
Deciding that of course is a challenge.
We did talk about cost-benefit and
the trade off that are there
when you think about
the deploying various solutions.
So, of course we want to do
into a cost effective manner.
It sounds simple, but doing that,
again, is a serious challenge.
Obviously we have to argue
that the cost is less than
the reduction in risk
we're going to have.
Finally, we know that when you look
at sort of the threat landscape, and
I think in the context
of database security,
we did the question where we said,
what are the threats?
External hackers or insiders,
and we say in one of the surveys,
insiders and unauthorized access was
ranked higher than external hackers.
So we have to of course, understand
the people and the process that we have.